do you think it's possible so the
javascript
used to be uh for the front end of the
web
it's now increasingly so being used for
back end like running and stuff that's
like behind the scenes and it's also
starting to be used uh quite a bit for
things like tensorflow.js
so starting to actually use like these
heavy-duty applications
that are using neural networks machine
learning and so on in the browser
is it possible in 10 20
30 years that basically most of the
world runs on javascript
this is a dystopia and a nightmare to
some people
um when i when we did ask them jason
webb assembly i would joke and meme
people with scenes like
neo waking up in his pod in the matrix
and he's all skinny and
weak and hairless um and you know
you realize in the future that you're
living in some simulation and it's all
running on javascript and you just
scream forever
um it's possible gary bernhard uh
does these funny talks he did wat js and
then he did this
uh life and death of javascript i think
it's called where he
he took some clever ideas that actually
have a a thread of
uh credibility to them but i mentioned
software
fault isolation in the old days when we
were using computers we
we said we're gonna use the unix you
know monolithic monitor and it's the
privileged program
this is before you even had hardware
rings of protection those some of the
early 60s operating systems used
hardware
protection zones but unix is privileged
and the
program that runs user code in a process
is
is hosted it's the guest in the host and
and you get to
suspend it you get to kill it if it
crashes it doesn't take down the whole
os it's a wonderful idea
um but the call into the kernel is
expensive the system calls so-called and
this has even been optimized now for
things like getting the time of day so
it doesn't actually
enter the kernel and meanwhile
hardware architectures and
virtualization techniques have gone in a
different direction
even to the point where you can do
software fault isolation very cheaply
without
entering the operating system kernels
you get unicorns and exokernels and
very lightweight vms and so gary took
this idea and said
javascript will take over computing
because the system call boundaries too
expensive so everything ends up in
javascript with these lighter weight
isolation enforcement mechanisms it's
not totally beyond belief yeah
um it's free webassembly too
you